the quiet of a dead forest
a reason perhaps to give up hope
europe's wildfires are the continent's
worst in a hundred years
but nature is resilient and where the
earth is scorched life is returning
though it will almost certainly never be
the same
a few days ago sobreros and spain's
avila province was surrounded by fires
celia morales played in these mountains
as a child
she says it was a magical place for kids
the fires came so close to the town
she filmed the flames from her front
garden
it made me feel very impotent because we
couldn't do anything it was very windy a
lot of people were shouting because they
were very nervous the mountain was full
of grass and brushes and everything
burned really quickly the whole thing
was a nightmare now we need to think
about rehabilitation
for small communities such as sobreros
life
is changing rapidly
climate change means less rain more heat
drier conditions and year on year more
intense wildfires environmental experts
agree that the best case scenario is
this is the new normal
[Music]
on the outskirts of madrid to prevent
future fires one mayor is championing
the old ways
javier de la nieto calls them
his little fireman
fundamentals
goats are essential to prevent fires in
a mediterranean climate like spain
because they are the only ones able to
feed on the leaves fruits and flowers of
plants like this one they clear the area
so fires are not as fast and hot and do
not burn as many hectares
other areas are adopting his program it
is subsidized by firefighters and is
even receiving eu support
where the goats graze he says there has
not been a serious fire in six years
but the spanish government won't let
delaniento use public land fearing over
grazing and a disruption to the natural
environment
however it is too late for that the
disruption he says has already happened
looking at the surrounding hillsides de
la nieto sees a bomb waiting to go off
and perhaps he says
the solution to man-made environmental
disasters
lies in nature itself
zayn vesravia al-jazeera spain